[Music]
anything you want to unburden yourself
with before
and
this
happens
yes
i have wishes
to bestow upon you
i
want to wish you
this heartbreak uh-oh
too late i wish for you to see out your
days alone as you always have been
watching pal
where are you going with this you
are a cancer to everyone who ever loved
you eddie
deceived your trusting fiance
and no wonder daddy could never look at
you again after you killed his wife your
mother
just by being
born this is about me wanting to live
without you whining in my ear all the
time about eating bad guys or like
nagging me about ann or destroying my
place or destroying my life do you know
how lucky you are i chose you you chose
me
buddy i'm the only person that took you
in when your friends kicked you off the
planet mingmon because you are a reject
you are a pariah lethal protection my
ass you couldn't protect anything you
are useless you can get a job down here
cleaning toilets
i'm sorry i don't know what came over me
please let me fix it again
[Music]
so
[Music]
okay
i wanted a crib close to the stadium
it's the bay rent's ridiculous so i got
some um
roommates
but this
this isn't what i signed up for i say
either
these guys
are not well
yummy eddie said my life wouldn't be in
danger i woke up this morning with a
tendril wrapped around my neck
not cool visiting chew tire in the
living room what's that about
these guys just don't even like each
other that was abusive which is bad
because they share a body venom's got no
chill you are a loser
yeah some of us are trying to sleep so
sick i don't know how to tell eddie it's
not working without triggering them
i respect that aggression on a football
field but not in my living room that's
the third time this week dude not cool
then on let there be carnage exclusively
in movie theaters october 1st
lady
we should be out there snacking on bad
guys
i am a predator
i need to be free you have got to get
control of your aggression
we will get hauled off into area 51.
you live in my body you live by my walls
i'm sorry i don't know what came over me
please let me fix it so i can fix it
again
you are a loser
eddie brock i want to give you my story
people love serial killers
jesus why me
that's mine
it's yours and what's yours
is mine
i have tasted blood before and that is
not it
all i ever wanted in this world
is carnage
i'm not a crazy man
i promise oh yeah
betty
you feel like home to me
like family
oh wow you could just say i'm happy for
you that was going to be us hey i'm
happy for you
i'm so sorry i'm sorry just doing some
serious couples counseling
i want to give you my story
cletus cassidy is a psychotic killer
people love serial killers who got
revenge on people that he felt were
responsible for his nasty upbringing
when he meets eddie brock you
and i are the same he sets his sights on
him it's only right that you hold the
door for me on my way out
peters finally breaks out the prisoners
carnage
carnage could change his molecular
structure to become anything
and his tendrils can be weaponised in
different ways
it was very exciting to finally see the
harness manifested on screen
now playing in this movie it's like the
seven year itch cycle of a relationship
i'm sorry i don't know what they want me
please let me fix it
again
you've got two characters that are
literally stuck to each other you live
in my body you live by my wolves
i was doing some serious couples
counseling that odd couple relationship
is what this movie was always going to
be about as a progression from the first
one excuse me
it's like living with an oversized
toddler they have had enough of each
other
they can't be together they can't be
apart but he's far too selfish venom
just wants to be the hero i am a
predator we should be out there snacking
on bad guys watching tommen as then in
the navy was so much fun
that is a red one you need to come out
right now
[Music]
in this film
weebly shriek shriek has the ability to
suck up sound and use it as a weapon
she can be really dangerous you're
sending me to a place where there
so she's been kept in a box at
ravencroft for 25 years
she only cares about one human being and
that's cletus
she's twisted like cletus happy days
they'll do anything to come back
together
together they're so much fun and
incredibly terrifying
[Applause]
[Music]
you